there is a really cool new experience
over at area 15.
it's a new exhibit called wink world and
it opens up today bianca holman is there
live for us this morning oh my bianca
good morning how is it
yes you see this glowing experience that
i'm in right now so this is a new
exhibit here
at area 15 it's called wink road it's
created by chris
and i understand your background kind of
helped you
create this kind of tell us more about
that that's right well blue man group
which is always one of the co-founders
of
we used a lot of black light um just to
kind of create a world for the blue man
that was uh very vivid
yeah and i have always since i was a kid
love black light
and just the bright colors the vibrance
of it you know it's hard to
not feel a sense of wonder when you're
in the presence of some bright things so
what we've done is we've created a real
world that has a lot of that black light
a lot of translucent items
and we've kind of converted silly things
like cutlery and slinkys and stuff
into like glow items and stuff and uh
just to kind of create a
whimsical but also kind of mysterious
space and the other thing that's fun
with black light is that you can do
sudden changes and you turn it off and
there's some phosphorescent elements
suddenly you go from color to like just
monochrome glow
and so i guess with blue man group we
love to combine music and light and
color
in a way that just surprised people and
almost felt like it was alive
and it this really works together and i
feel like that these slinkies are very
much alive
and it kind of goes with the music just
like in the rooms that we're about to
see coming up in the portals
these six portals that we're going to
enter it's like a dream coming true and
so
while people may see this and they think
it's only for kids no this is like
adult playland too that's right it's a
perfect way to say it because i think we
want to create
a sense for adults that they're kind of
playing in a playground
and so yeah this is very much a place
for grown-ups but kids like it too
for sure all right so you can see we're
kind of like in the gift shop area where
you got to get your glow stuff you know
you see i got my knives you know
i'm kind of spicy right you know slice
them and dice them got my spoon headband
we're about to go into these rooms next
coming up in the six o'clock hour we're
gonna send it back to you guys in the
studio
i'm glad you're having fun today